please welcome all the way from Chicago
Illinois Sebastian Maniscalco
I think it's very cool to see a stand-up
turn into this leading man type guy and
Sebastian does it very well
watching him as a comic he is a natural
actor he embodies these characters that
he tells stories about and scenarios on
stage so it's a very natural leap for
him to now be in front of a camera
opposite Robert De Niro I was happy to
do this I always like to give advice
especially if someone wants it but if I
feel I have something to contribute of
course so and so he he did ask me a few
things in a scene or two which was good
nightclub
good
seeing Sebastian perform alongside
Robert De Niro really brought out the
best in him as a performer because
acting is very different than stand-up
comedy we'll stand up you hear the
laughter right away you know right in
the moment if you're doing well or
you're doing terrible with this you
don't hear nothing everybody's like
silent so it's been a different muscle
to get used to for me